tiene 63 años y nació en when you la
cuna de los mejores empresarios chinos y
atendemos a la creencia popular tiene la
complicada misión de reflotar una
economía arranqueante Después de tres
años de covid apenas creció al 3% el
pasado año quejaba del bajo consumo
interno y con los palos en las ruedas de
Estados Unidos cada vez más hostil en su
guerra tecnológica Lee tiene fama de
pragmático y de defender el sector
privado lo demostró en su provincia
natal de Jean y después en Shanghai ahí
multiplicó la inversión extranjera por
ejemplo con la megafábrica de tesla la
primera que se levantaba fuera de
Estados Unidos tiene un currículum una
contrapelo en la casuística china no
había habido antes un Primer Ministro
sin experiencia en el consejo de estado
tampoco tiene experiencia en las
ponencias Rurales un requisito que se
suele exigir a los más altos políticos
en China para asegurarse que tienen todo
el país en la cabeza a cambio Si tiene
la confianza absoluta de Chasing con
quien trabajó codo con codo décadas
atrás en yang lille mostró toda su
fidelidad el año pasado haciendo cumplir
a rajatabla la política de cero covid
Durante los dos meses de encierro en
Shanghai no hay dudas de que lee tiene
aptitudes para el cargo Sí hay dudas de
si va a poder disfrutar de un gran
margen de actuación su predecesor like
chang fue en pequeñecido por chisen Pin
y no pudo llevar a cabo las reformas que
se le presuponían Es probable que el
nuevo Primer Ministro gracias a la
afinidad que tiene vaya a gozar de más
libertad